it's just one dude I play games where I
looks like my way out yeah yeah
welcome to the heilwald loophole this
game is fascinating to me it's a
PlayStation 1 style horror game which
should you know get a lot of attention
in and of itself but it's it actually
hasn't gotten that many people playing
it only uh like a hundred or so reviews
on Steam but they're all glowing they're
all impeccable they all say things like
um as of writing my favorite indie
horror game of all time good visuals
interesting gameplay concept very
interesting story killer sound design
phenomenal horror game nice slasher one
of the best perhaps the only time Loop
based PlayStation style horror games
I've ever played unexpectedly good at
straddling the line between terrifying
bizarre and hilarious so I'm curious
right
[Music]
oh game lets you know when you've missed
something this is recommended no hand
holding here you'll have to do some
exploring uh given that it's a longer
game on my to do guided mode just
because I don't know what the hell I'm
doing here
[Music]
foreign
uh
um
I don't know how you control that
I don't know what that's supposed to do
I I that sounded more like I was being
birthed it might be of note
there's a massive hole in the ceiling
strange how it collapsed in exactly this
spot where I was standing
that is weird
huh
uh
great
um so
all right
oh
okey-dokey then
I'm here I'm guessing the Highland
loophole is referring to this concept
where no one dies here and therefore do
whatever you can to exploit that or make
that rule law
I think anyway
where am I I wonder what they're storing
here we are of the same mind you and I
two doors
oh my God wait a minute
[Music]
what the hell happened Dr Randolph was
quite concerned about your behavior you
appeared paranoid and actively tried
avoiding his Aid he plans on
accommodating you in the prison
temporarily the prison
why the prison
but good this is much less paranoia
inducing than where I was
thank you for understanding my needs
anybody getting Vibes at presentable
Liberty
oh
uh yeah
[Music]
the heilwale clinicum says goodbye to
Fred okay the an article about the old
Chief doctor resigning
sounds like he was quite beloved
yeah I'm sure he was
um
why am I here
thank goodness paper is Russell so
loudly
must be this wind rustling through this
place
ah
I could see how that would be nice just
if the weather was a little better
um
well that's a big door
well I am intrigued
I am more than intrigued
I am captivated well that's all locked
so I guess I go this way
hello
[Music]
okay
was that supposed to be just an alarm or
weird
is this gonna fall
is this how I fall
[Music]
um
all right I'm back I've looped
the same
could be interesting just a bunch of
boxes that wasn't interesting at all
massive hole in the ceiling why are the
descriptions different
okay that's still locked so that makes
sense
okay
all right so is he still going to be
standing I wonder what their story is he
still going to be standing um
or Yonder way oh a bunch of empty
syringes okay well that's
maybe there are unused ones around ah
man I bet that's something that I need
to know about
um but at the same time
[Music]
hey doctor
it was up
oh you know
I'm sorry
all right I'm following you really
closely do you have a tail what is going
on there
um what's this seems to be out of place
you damn right uh what's that what's
that you talking about the tail
all right I'll close it don't worry
I'm here
okey dokey then I'm here
yes
don't have a season please
[Music]
foreign
obviously
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh did you take it
welcomes Joseph Randolph he is to take
the role of Chief doctor
apparently there were a lot of
applicants
how did he manage to get the job I
wonder he can remove a liver in three
seconds flat
like some kind of a record oh
well that seems special
I choose to go in the scary event
not because it is easy but because it is
hard
and because I have a sneaking suspicion
now my liver might get stolen if I do
not oh can I not go this way really
I feel like I could squeeze through
there
oh
good
oh we're back here again
ah of course it is
that's weird all right here I go
this is fascinating items of knowledge
two of nine
wow
again it sounds more like a birthing
than it does um
a collapsing so there's gotta be a way
to get away from this doctor let me try
the obvious
yep
oh
this probably is not the correct
almost definitely not the correct
oh maybe there's a way to like unlock
this
huh
[Music]
what
I was almost certain I would be
hit end
[Music]
foreign
okay I hear him walking around the hall
out there
it's got to be a way that I could sneak
around him
thank you for opening that door
whatever this is is this is helpful more
clutter damn
helpful
[Music]
all right this might take some doing
where is he
I don't know
[Music]
where'd he go
oh oh oh where is he oh
frick
Africa might be of no
[Music]
dude
this might be a good place to wait for
him to go by
[Music]
who
must have been a nightmare to go through
yeah not the thoughts I want right now
oh
empties God damn it that's not what I'm
looking for
oh I'm stressed
this is stressful
very stressful why is this so stressful
I don't know is this one dude I play
games where I looks like my way out yeah
yeah
my God
why would you do that to me
why I went through all of that just so
you could hop on my back all right fine
I'll do it again
I gotta be a way out of here
[Music]
so I can slip past him pretty okay but
it seemed like he was not about me going
um
going uh towards that staircase so
there's got to be other things that are
lurking around the corners here more
secrets to see golden toilets something
about that hello
go away
where are you going shut up also
[Music]
brick oh frick oh he's gonna walk in
here oh God
[Music]
no
bye
foreign
[Music]
okay that's good to know
maybe this is what I was supposed to do
I'm out of here baby
so what's in his office and I don't
I'll stick around too long because we'll
be right back
nothing
good what's this
whoa what it Where what is that
it's a plug
it's glued shut and taped shut what is
going on
what in the world is that supposed to be
he's coming
Lord he common
ly
[Music]
we
will we will
we will
[Music]
okay so this is the same place I was
before
[Music]
doesn't really want anyone going this
way I know and I've been here but this
was locked
so what was the point of any of this
okay well I'm not gonna be caught here
yay
where are you going shut up also you're
ugly
[Music]
oh my God where what is this an unused
syringe I'm Gonna Get You
this is how I do a donut
[Music]
come on come on
come on I got him
yes yes yes
got it that's what you get that's what
you get so stay down I don't care who
you are you're down so I'm gonna go this
way and I'm gonna go down these stairs
and you're not gonna wake up looks like
my way out oh yeah it is because I got
this oh yeah
mm-hmm
while scouring through the office's
storage room you discover some leftover
anesthetics you don't care if they're
expired all you want to do is get rid of
Dr Randolph and whatever sick treatment
he has in mind for you thus you manage
to escape into the sick Ward
thanks that was shockingly stressful
what
I'm guessing that was probably just like
a um
a tutorial level but still that was
incredibly stressful and I don't know
why
okay I won't go back I shouldn't go back
I refuse to go back
can I leave
home home this is not home but this is
not a home
that's not um
oh
all right
um
sure looks inviting this guy's an idiot
this doesn't look inviting at all
why am I getting Cry of Fear Vibes I
haven't thought of Cry of Fear in a long
time I
how are you
[Music]
oh
yep that's bad
rubber
cobra
I like Kroger
another plug great yeah I don't get it
I I don't get that
I don't understand anything about that
God I gotta revisit cry fear someday
I remember that I never got the actual
ending like the true ending in that game
because I just didn't
I wasn't motivated enough to go through
it all over again but man that would be
a crazy one
uh
this is just bad vibes
this is nothing but bad vibes
what oh hey don't I got the doors closed
I did not it was that's not working it's
not working
why are you so
Stompy
oh I'm going for it oh no close oh no
where'd you come from was there any
point no there wasn't
oh you okay
it's so filthy yep
[Music]
okay horrible
must be important the reception oh she's
stomping oh God oh God
[Music]
good
oh what's up with your head oh okay bye
sensitive about it okay if that's locked
and that's locked and you're there
don't come this way
where are you oh
I'm gonna run for it oh bad idea what is
over here bathroom
oh could be interesting what did what is
that what is that
oh no close it oh no oh
no
[Music]
I'm pooping
God I'm pooping
[Music]
go for it
oh she's Stumpy oh God what's this oh
what's this oh I already been here have
I been here I've been here I've been
yeah I've been here okay all right well
I don't know what to do about that
that's horrible
a very horrible um but I have a crowbar
is that gonna help me in any way maybe
over here
[Music]
like if I take the Crowbar and do
something with it I don't have an
inventory do I no I won't go back I
shouldn't go back
gone that way I've gone in here I don't
really see anything here
oh do I have to like give her a sedative
I don't I don't know if I have a
sedative
take oh I don't I don't I don't oh I I
don't
I don't I don't know where to get a
sedative there's got to be another
Saturday for something around here all
right you know what
stop
oh my God
whoa
Heidel trout takes good care of her
patience at least she likes to say so
but seeing you run around a reward with
an unwieldy and dangerous crowbar was
too much she deems electric shock
therapy a reasonable treatment
does she deem that well it's a good
thing she deems that
she deems real nice oh
maybe I needed to get God
maybe oh I I just get to sit in a
waiting room oh that wasn't nearly as
bad as I thought it would be there's a
there's an invisible wall
wartum
I think it means maintenance
yep
sure
aha
wait wait wait wait wait wait don't do
it I don't want to be doing it don't do
it
okay
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna not follow
someone I think
oh
all right I'll be right here
wow this is going swimmingly
unfortunately I think that might be all
the time I have for this life
um
this is a longer game I believe it
clocks in probably around three years
hello I've waited basically hello
so I'm going to see what this is all
about and then
I'm sure everything will be fine you
have such long arms
I find that to be
oh my God
all right you got it oh yep
I'm ready
zap me up
foreign
[Music]
the last thing you see is ants Twisted
grinning face staring right at you as he
bumps eye voltage through your entire
body is this the end you kind of wish it
was but alas there is more more
ah I see
so this is where I am yeah
I'm fascinated by this this is so much
more than I thought it would be I do
feel a strong compulsion to keep playing
it which maybe I will there's a paper
rustling over here which is useful I
think
a research paper published by Joseph
Randolph benefits of the surgical
remover of the Iker
don't really understand what he's
talking about in this paper doesn't make
it sound like it's the next big thing I
just want to see if this dumps me back
at the very beginning because that means
I would oh
oh
fascinating
weird I think I'm Gonna Leave This here
for now and at some point in the future
I might pick this up but uh definitely
give this game a try it's
it's fascinating so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you thought down in the comments below
and if you want to see more of it let me
know down there as well thank you and as
always I will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]